(fast-paced drumming music)
[Man] What time is it?
♪ This is the dawning
of the age of Aquarius ♪
"Summer of Soul"
is about the Harlem
Cultural Festival in 1969.
With so many
greats of music in the day,
Tony Lawrence and Hal
Tulchin came up with an idea
that we need to throw
a beautiful soul festival
to use music to heal
a community that's hurting.
♪ Let the sun shine ♪
And when it came time
to distributing,
they couldn't find any takers.
In fact, a counterpart festival
that happened about 10 days
later called Woodstock,
pretty much got to define
an entire generation.
We wanted progress.
We're black people
and we should be proud of this.
The day that we got
nominated for an Academy Award,
I was just flabbergasted
because I did not go into
this project
thinking that I was
going to make something
that would affect people
emotionally like this.
Getting nominated
really isn't about me,
it's about documenting
a moment in time
and the world's gonna see it.
When you see films about
the Civil Rights era,
there's one slight area
that always gets overlooked,
Black joy.
Black joy humanizes us.
And "Summer of Soul"
is just an awesome look
at beautiful people having fun
in a way that you've never
seen anyone from this era look.
♪ Gonna let my hair down
in Harlem ♪
♪ 125th Street,
now here I come ♪